hey everyone how are you doing thanks
I'm from Harlem so we do this kind of
call-and-response thing it's not just in
crypto so that feels good or if you feel
like I'm home alright let's let's rock
boom okay so this is a New York Times
article and you know we're here at this
amazing event talking to other devs all
kinds of devs even 150 devs who wouldn't
normally be here
who are making this conference awesome
by being here thanks to those
sponsorships I got to speak to someone
during lunch who's from st. Louis and
she just talked to me about what it's
like being here these events that seem
to plague the city people come from
outside and have their own views and if
you are here and you have the
opportunity to talk to someone who is
from this town or outside this area
please do is whether they work at one of
the conference centers or they're an
attendee you know I work with
marginalized people all around the world
protecting them from digital threats and
there some places where I work where you
cannot protest and it's frightening so
as much as it's an inconvenience or it's
something that we talk about it's
probably one of the most American things
that you can do so
[Applause]
okay opportunity grants not has n to do
with my talk but I just want to put our
hands together for the people who are
around us who got these grants and we're
able to come you make this conference
better
you know technology isn't like a thing
anymore it's like the blood that flows
through every part of the world all
countries all places we don't have any
space for not bringing people in we need
people who are older when you go to a
tech conference you should see people
who are in their 60s and 70s walking
around too because that'll be you in the
future if there's no place for those
people there's no place for you there
should be all kinds of people you know
queer people intersex people all kinds
of folks you know like those are my
people because you know what when I was
going into the tech there was no
opportunity it was just a weird hobby
when I got into hacking it was just
something I like to do and I had to put
it away there wasn't like a Facebook or
Google to go to and luckily my weird
hobby turned into the thing that kind of
runs the planet so whoo okay but um we
need everyone to be part of that and we
need tech to be a lot bigger and a lot
more open than it is we need to kind of
blow the doors off of it and I can see
that in the people that I've met at
strange loop over the past two days it's
pretty amazing you know like I'm used to
going to hacker conference this at a
hacker conference there's like only one
type of human let alone any other thing
right like it's just a hoodie covered
person who needs to take a shower you
know all right let's move on okay are
you aligned with the work you do you
know I I didn't think about that before
I would just go to a interview because
it was like a cool place to work and
then you know they have you know how it
is you're like an eight hour interview
you know it's like an interrogation
whiteboards and tech challenges and then
like a tech challenge maybe like over
the phone and then you get the offer
letter and you're like oh sweat they
actually are giving me what I asked for
right so you sign that offer and you
meet these cool people but then after a
year or two years it's not so cool
anymore
and every place has their expiration
date where you to choose between being a
lifer or moving on and then you start
that process over and over again but for
what were like what are we doing that
for just to get a higher salary I mean
are we really being challenged if you
are being challenged at your job and you
really enjoy that stuff then stay there
but make sure that it's a place that's
aligned with you what you believe and I
found
that the work I was doing was not
aligned with me and so I made a change
and that's what I'm talk to all you
about just about this little trapdoor
that isn't easy to find this trapdoor
that I had to find and figure out I'm
just giving you my secrets so if any of
you need to take it it'll be right there
for you more like an elevator has anyone
gone on one of those social good
hackathons put your hands up if you have
anyone right and then keep your hands up
if you actually tried to maintain that
thing you worked on afterwards good sir
you're awesome it's hard we're busy
people not only do we work like Amazon
employees but no shade Amazon you know
but we have lives we're trying to have
relationships and we're socially awkward
people all right
so how can we find time to do this stuff
nights and weekend projects usually go
astray that github repo with all that
activity all those green blocks
disappear in terms of gray it's pretty
sad but there's a better way I figured
it out and I'm sharing it with you
Public Interest technologists it's a
thing what is a Public Interest
technologist well in law there's this
thing called a public interest lawyer
you know I'm the child of immigrants and
if anyone here has an immigrant or
refugee parent all they want is you
become a doctor or a lawyer that's all
you want right because to them that's
what a professional is they don't know
about engineers in code or DevOps or you
know people do penetration testing all
this other stuff like that right in law
lawyers just went to work for people who
had tons of money and it wasn't until
the 60s and 70s in this country that
lawyers actually worked for the public
good
Lauria started working more into the
Department of Justice lawyers started
working more as all kinds of attorneys
in different communities right that
wasn't by accident we have this totally
weird
60s and 70s political turmoil
assassinations left and right all kinds
of things going
in the world and in this country but it
was the funding of organizations like
Ford Foundation and others that allowed
this to be a real practice they they
allowed you to just sign up to be a
public interest lawyer and then they
would help you get this law school and
then they would help you get a position
afterwards and public interest law firms
there's lots of them now and that's all
because of that and those same people
are interested in something called a
Public Interest technologist because
they see all these great minds it's like
a brain drain you know when I travel
around the world I'm like hey we're you
computer scientists they're like oh
they're at MIT they're not here you know
that's what happens with our great minds
they go to Facebook and Google and
Amazon no shade y'all all right they
don't go to ACLU they don't go to
Southern Poverty Law Center they don't
go to these other amazing places because
how do you do that anyway like is it
gonna be like a hackathon where I'm
gonna spend all my time and get no money
and I'm gonna work on really simple
challenges that aren't really great and
I'm not gonna be respected in my field
there's no path and someone needs to
push ahead and make that path for us
okay so Who am I I'm a Mozilla open web
fellow I'll tell you more about
fellowships I was at this place called
color change which is a civil rights
organization the United States but
they're unlike double-a-c-p and other
civil rights organizations they're one
that's totally about tech inside and out
from day one I'm an Internet freedom
Festival fellow and that's a conference
that I hope to see many of you at and
I'll talk more about it later I'm a new
America cybersecurity initiative fellow
and all these things are going to expire
so you know I got to start to find some
new things right but um I got the
Institute for the future still who'd
would I'm a future for good fellow and
that's that's still going on I'm an
advisor to the open Technology Fund and
I'll talk to you more about what that is
and I'm a developer and a data
journalist and I used to work at the New
York Times I'm a hacker and I work for
the benefit of civil society nonprofits
NGOs put it together people cut them out
thank you
big coins heading your way sir
nonprofits NGOs human rights defenders
that's who called me on a hourly basis
right I'm the founder of an event called
crypto Harlem Harlem
anybody know okay just check just
checking that's a little too quiet I
knew okay so this is where crypto Harlem
happens and I started crypto Harlem
quite a few years ago you know I thought
you know there's a lot of crazy things
going on and especially where I am where
I live I should do something so I went
to this Community Center and I said hey
can you give me some space to talk about
the dangers of surveillance digital
safety digital security and all that
kind of stuff so all the tinfoil hats
can see that they're not alone right and
they they were like yeah let's do it and
then it blew up you know and I'm going
to show you how to have a slide just
like that that's what I'm gonna do I'm
giving you the recipe two slides like
this one okay cuz I need I need some
company alright I'm an operational
security and information security
trainer at this organization called
global journal of security they're a
for-profit entity that does hostile
environmental emergency first aid
trainings if you're a journalist and
you're going to cover you know Maria or
one of these hurricanes you need to know
what to do if someone Falls to your left
or right if you go to Syria or
Afghanistan Iran or even just a protest
down the street you need to know what to
do if things go sideways and global
journal security they simulate that you
go to their campsite you're hanging out
with other reporters then all of a
sudden in the middle of the night
someone comes and takes it puts a hood
over your head and throws you in a car
you know you've been kidnapped because
they know that we're all intelligent
people but when stuff happens we act
really stupid and if someone doesn't
take you there to that horribly
stressful place you don't know if you're
crying all the time or laughing all the
time or whatever but it's not the right
thing and you need to train that version
of you that kind of tenure role you what
to do and I work with them creating
digital threats so I can train
journalists activists human rights
defenders
what to do when they're fished or their
phone gets spoofed
or some other thing happens because if
you don't make it real
it's just something another thing that
you're supposed to do you don't realize
that that bulletproof vest and that
helmet and that press badge is all you
have between life and death I'm also a
digital safety and security coach for
the movement for black lives which is an
organization of 50 organization it's
kind of an umbrella group inside that
organ that group are all these groups
that are committed to helping black
folks in the United States some of them
you know like black lives matter some of
them maybe you know maybe you don't like
black youth project 100 but when they
have us anything that they need
assistance on this digital realm I'm
there to help them because I solve
identifies black and it's in my best
interest but also because I care and
I've done that for environmental
activists because I'm a vegan 16 years I
saw that long veggie line so my veggie
people right well let me take you back
let me take you back to where it all
started okay let's rewind I was a little
kid with an afro all right I talked
about my immigrant parents they wanted
me to be a professional but I just loved
comic books and Star Wars that was my
thing you know and I just wanted a
computer but they couldn't afford it so
they got me a computer magazine
subscription so I read it every day was
called compute if anyone's old enough to
remember that thing compute heads right
and everything in there was like in
assembly if it's like Makino so you do
like right I used to write the code in a
little graph paper and pretend I was
typing it in
so I imaginary computer and if I could
beg borrow steal some time on one of my
friends computers I was doing crazy
stuff you know they were like well I got
the high score and like you know summer
games and all that yes and that's
nothing you know because of that need
you know that curiosity I was like
running with weights on and when I had a
computer I was flying and I became a
hacker but I had a career-ending injury
which is I'm an empath if you trip and
fall I don't laugh I worry about you I
can't steal people's computers software
files money cybercrime just it was like
not for me and
back when I was a hacker that was like
the number one and only thing to do so I
just put that away
fast forward a little bit I was too
small
February 26th 2012 is a date that
changed my life forever I didn't even
realize how much I would change me but
when I look back that's kind of like
when it all started
that's Trayvon Martin and his dad
Trayvon Martin died February 26th 2012
and I heard about it I'm like some
random tweet like it was not covered in
the media it was not in the news but
that was like the first time that people
realized hey we can do more than citizen
journalism we can take stories and this
push them up to social media algorithms
were a lot easier and that's what
happened and you know it was all over
the news I was looking for a new job and
I thought I need to get away from all
this stress so I got job at CNN I don't
thinking okay it was like I'm working
and every day I'm hearing all these
stories about this case and more new
details and things like that you know
and it's kind of weird when when you're
a marginalized person whether you're
older and tech or a woman in tech or
black in tech they're going to be things
that happen in this world you know and
one of these things happen you're going
to be affected but your co-workers is
not impacting them the same way you know
when you hear about a venture capitalist
that sexually harassing people that
affects you but it doesn't affect your
co-workers and I was very frustrating
for me because I was just trying to do a
great job you know do my mobile web
stuff and do my mobile stuff and you
know be a great engineer and you know I
was in the newsroom around all the stuff
constantly as a data journalist I was
very tricky it's kind of painful and
then on the day of the verdict in New
York Union Square I felt like compelled
to go but none of my co-workers were
going you know in fact I was kind of
like couldn't even talk to them about
like do you want to come so if you have
a friend at work even if something weird
happens that's super embarrassing if you
feel that it might impact them I'm
giving you permission to say hey can we
talk about this thing that happened do
you have any feelings or thoughts about
it
because it makes all the difference in
the world because the people we work
with just because we got it same
interview that they did and we passed it
like they did we see them more than
people we love we see the more other
people we hate in this world working
like an Amazon employee we see them more
than anything so let's treat them like
human beings you know not just people
with the stand up a little bit further
on in that same year Edward Snowden
flees to Hong Kong and the Snowden
revelations start to pour out and it's
like an earthquake in the hacker digital
security digital safety space all the
activists I know were like whoa all
those crazy paranoid tinfoil hat people
were right you know
and I need to book a ticket to Hong Kong
you know for me these two events came
too close to each other and I was
reeling what kind of world did I live in
everything seemed to not make sense so I
started this thing called crypto Harlem
I wanted to talk about the Snowden
revelations I wanted to talk about
police violence and I thought who better
than the people who look like me and my
community so after work even though I
worked like pretty late I would go to
the community center and try to do this
thing
twelve times a year I would spend three
hours walking around because in Harlem
you can't put stuff on Meetup it just
doesn't work that way you know I tried
actually so you know I had to go to the
barber shop I had to go to the salon I
had to go to the pastor of the church
and the Imam at the mosque and I gave
them my flyer and I talked to them you
know I talked to the little grannies and
I said it's a free computer class you
know so the brothers on the corner I was
like hey this is how you keep people out
of your phone because to me digital
safety and encryption that's a right
it's like literacy and whatever you do
with it is up to you if you want to read
fantasy books all day or if you want to
read medical books that's up to you but
you need to know how to be digitally
safe and we're all walking around
clueless you know I was at this talk
earlier today with Garrett and Yan and
they were blowing minds because as
developers from when we write our first
hello world to when we're making six
figures and you know we don't know
anything about application security and
we're totally clueless and that's what
it's like with the regular folks walking
around you know they don't know anything
about how easy it is to pull their data
away and who's doing it I mean I know if
I see the
at a conference every year so then I got
this good job
I left CNN I got this job of the New
York Times and I thought okay fresh
start everything's cool things seem to
be chill now I can try to like be my
best self and commit myself to my work
but right after that I started going to
these conferences you know at the Times
I found that like a lot of reporters
they were like hey should I email this
to this source and things like that and
it was right after the Snowden
revelations really like the impact was
just still hitting people people didn't
know what to do and as a hacker I just
was screaming no no no no no you know so
even though I'm there
writing stuff in Ruby I'm like yeah yeah
we need to talk about encrypting your
email we need to talk about the best way
to send this file so you know one person
talking to me at lunch turned into two
people turned to three people then I was
the most popular person going out like
to the bar telling people how to encrypt
their stuff you know I've committed to
protect journalists and reporters
committee for freedom of the press
invited me to their events and I
attended and met other people who work
in use and other people who work with
dissidents and human rights defenders
and they were making a real impact but
then I would leave that and go back to
work you know and I would take a look at
what was in my queue and take a look
like what was in the repo and take a
look at the room our roadmap I just kind
of continue that and it felt really
didn't feel right you know I didn't feel
like I was making the same impact I was
building sandcastles that were literally
gonna be washed away the next day and
then Michael Brown died that's when I
couldn't take it anymore and that's when
I thought I have to do something what
good is this knowledge of technology and
its ability to do these things if I'm
just sitting at a standing desk all day
and even though every other week you
know how it is right I hope you got the
little soft thing underneath make sure
you get that all right every other week
I had a little reminder why I was doing
it when the paycheck dropped you know
but it wasn't enough it felt like I was
like you know not doing the right thing
and that's what I mean was not being
aligned with your work like I'm not
gonna tell you what to believe I'm not
gonna tell you what caused us to fight
for but whatever it is that makes you
different from the other people at work
or the developers next to you that's the
thing that you have to make sure you're
aligned with you know give to that thing
even if I don't agree with your politics
it does not matter
you are gifted with technology and it's
not just a way to get a paycheck it's
bigger than that so let's say I
convinced to you you know Matt the
recruiter right and some of you are
thinking yeah I felt that way sometimes
or hmmm okay I'll give it to you like I
want to get started right away I had
something Donna going like skunk works
on the side and I think it's gonna make
a difference in the world it's gonna
help people I would recommend that you
take it to the open tech fund take
pictures people although these will get
posted and the video will get posted
right open Technology Fund is part of
the State Department
it's from BBG which is like the kind of
like governor's thing and they um
Radio Free Asia Voice of America that
kind of like hey America's great type of
stuff that's that same area that same
funding but open tech fund is different
open tech fund is here to make it very
simple and easy to fill out a web form
because you have an idea that's going to
help people outside the United States
something that's to do with tech
something that's open source something
that's lightweight and it can like fly
and they will fund it you know when I
was first starting on this venture I
think well you know do I need to go over
a venture capitalist I need to find
someone who works your social good stuff
no no no I mean they're out there but
that's not the path to success who here
uses this app call signal anybody heard
of it all those hands go up people who
don't have it go install that you're
allowed to like just install right now
open tech fun gave moxie the first
funding for signal signal is a free app
because it's run by a very small team of
like four committed people may five
depending on what day it is and they're
very lightweight and it's very smart and
the double wrap double ratchet
encryption schema of of signal crypto is
amazing and it's so amazing that Moxie
is able to take it to other places like
whatsapp or or Google and charge them
you know for working and teaching them
how to do this and how to implement it
you know and that's how this app stays
free if you're ever using an app know
the politics of the people who use it
you know
if it's the dreadlock - anarchist I
might be pretty good you know know where
the money comes from because that makes
all the difference because we all know
what it's like when you're sitting on
all that user data and things aren't
been working out you know open tech
phone will give you up to nine hundred
thousand dollars and as little as ten
thousand so you got to ask for at least
ten thousand okay so aim high
your average grant goes out is $300,000
I don't know how much you make every
year but I think that's enough to make
you okay that's enough for you to think
about maybe using this trap door there's
another thing called the open knowledge
fund or open knowledge International and
it's the German version of the open tech
fund funded by the German government and
the applications in in German and you or
someone on your team needs to be a
German resident but if you are able to
do that you can get again three hundred
thousand dollars for your app you don't
just get money you also get people who
are going to give you you know in pen
testing you know
and security testing and other people
who are working to help you make this
the best it can be to help people you
know people who need it desperately then
if that's a little too much you feel a
little weird taking that much money
there's a group go fight for the future
and they've this a thing called a teams
and if you are an a-team it just means
that you're someone who's gonna make
technology or some kind of activism or
some kind of thing to make an impact
because this administration is different
from others and you're gonna challenge
that you will receive $15,000 for
filling out a webform about your idea
why not try it get it off the ground
how's it talk going so far by the way
good yeah all right cool thank you no
seriously thank you
okay if you want to leave your job or
take a sabbatical you just want to try
out this thing I'm talking to you about
right like because that's crazy right
you're on the line you have this like
app idea hundreds of thousand dollars
given to you by some nation state maybe
you want to just like you know try a
little different all right you want to
make sure you wake up every morning you
know all right you know what Angela
Merkel
yeah just took my money right okay
there's this thing called net game and
net game is a collection of funders
foundations working together for the
first time ever on one thing which is
creating Public Interest technologists
right neck pain partnership is a Ford
Foundation John D Catherine T MacArthur
Foundation Jonathan James L Knight
Foundation open society foundation and
Mozilla all those organizations are
funders Mozilla is a nonprofit that owns
a for-profit the Mozilla Firefox OS you
know long you know okay and but also
Firefox browser and other projects and
initiatives Mozilla funds you'll see
Mozilla stickers and conferences that
you go to
because Mozilla is a nonprofit that
cares and together with their tech
skills other people who have deeper
pockets who've been doing this longer
you know Ford Foundation is started by
Henry Ford of the Model T's brother and
you know they're sitting on a billion
dollars of money billions awarding
millions all these organizations were
already giving 50 million dollars a year
to try to create Public Interest
technologists but now they got together
and they're giving an additional like
maybe like 10 million or something like
that towards this goal right now the
people who've gotten this are New
America Foundation they're open tech
Institute they're they have this thing
called tech congress which is getting
technologists to work with government
officials you might think the government
has awesome tech people but sometimes
the people signing bills that affect us
every day for the work that we do and
the things that we believe in the apps
and the code that we write they have no
idea how it works and it's dangerous so
this initiative is getting taken
colleges to spend a year with a
congressperson to go to DC and teach
them about tech and make a difference
there are other people who've received
this money there's um
Mozilla has an MIT Media Lab and they
work with different executives to teach
them about technology teach them about
digital safety steer them in the right
direction because you're not going to
get that anywhere else
Public Interest technologies are part of
all these things Harvard University's
data privacy lab code for America this
money comes from net gain the media
democracy fund which is part of new
venture funds which is organization that
can give you the funding you need if
you're gonna do something that helps
people you know in a world of fake news
in a world of all this chaos what are we
using our skills for you don't have to
go alone
you don't have to sit there in a
Starbucks you know you can do it the
right way I was a Mozilla open web
fellow the open web fellowship is
something that they worked on with Ford
Foundation Ford needed a partner to help
steer this technology like this with
technology program what is the
technologists technologists could be an
artist the designer could be a user
experience person could be a system
admin person could be someone who writes
algorithms I met all these types of
people through this program and hundreds
of people apply to open web fellowship
they only picked when I was a fellow
eight people it was like winning the
lottery it literally changed my life
with this fellowship I was awarded
$60,000 $3,000 about technology budget
to build something for my lab and I was
made to go around the world meeting with
all kinds of experts in the field and
dignitaries all paid for by Mozilla and
Ford I was speaking at conferences and a
lot of the work that I did quietly was
now picking up and getting a lot of
attention this program put people in
organizations like Amnesty International
the ACLU hollaback you don't need to do
anything but apply and then if you get
it you don't have to take it you worry
about it you know
maybe you will and maybe you'll take
that ridiculous pay cut right and you're
not working the same way it feels great
when you walk out of work and the Sun
still up it's pretty wild there's
another group called Institute for the
future or that as they called the
Institute
it's very Dharma Initiative I know but
stay with me on it you know they have a
thing the feature for good because they
know that the world needs technologists
and there in Palo Alto where
technologists swim right and they create
this think tank that's going to take
technologists and intersect them with
the right moment in a government or in a
policy discussion or with commercial
organizations to come up with ideas of
what the future will be like that only a
futuristic technologies can come up with
if you get this fellowship it's kind of
a one-year commitment but it's very
lightweight with Mozilla you have to
move if the host organizations in Hong
Kong you have to go to Hong Kong they
get to the visa they get you the money
you know people I met were from Africa
India England even San Francisco you
know it's dude for the future it's like
you just I went to one event you know I
went to Iceland it was amazing I met
with the pirate party people who I've
read about and know know for a long time
and members who've I've met in the
hacker conferences but now I was there
with the people who were in Iceland
trying to make the party do great work
you know you didn't after you do this
you know maybe like three-day conference
thing you have to do some video chats
maybe good an event that they have and
that's it they don't ask a lot of you
not all these fellowships are things
that you can do that you have to leave
your job for some of them you can just
work out with your manager new America
cybersecurity initiative had cyber
security policy fellows hacking is
everywhere and if this past election
hasn't taught us anything it's that our
enemies are everywhere inside our
computers right and if the people
creating policy for this nation don't
understand
truly
anything about cybersecurity information
security then the policies can be wrong
and they can hurt the freedom of the
internet and actually end up not being
effective
so with this the policy fellows they
write a research paper they're given a
stipend for the paper they attend two
events some new Americas new America
annual event and new Americas the future
of war which i think is a little
presumptuous but you know you know cyber
war is a real thing you know the future
of war you're surrounded by people with
like you know all kinds of metals on
their jackets you know hackers who you
know work in little boxes for the US
government Ford Foundation is they
called tech fellow program the tech
Fuller program is like a longer
commitment it's two years and you have
to go to New York and work for the Ford
Foundation foreign fundation pays for
you to move pay for you to fly over
there and you work in the Ford
Foundation making them better because
they need technologists they need your
code but they really need your minds
your aspirations and your dreams to help
steer this foundation to make sure that
they're giving the right way helping
nations and countries all over this
world and helping people right next door
and if you watch PBS I'm sure you're
gonna see for a foundation on some
documentary that you watched Tech
Congress which I brought up before is
getting technologists with congressmen
and the application for tech Congress is
due yesterday so send it out immediately
I don't know Congress maybe they don't
even notice or am take Congress is
amazing like I know some of the fellows
who were chosen for this last cohort and
they're really affecting real change one
conversation can stop something that
would need to be BFF we'd have to like
you know sign a newsletter for like
three months and you know people
marching in the streets right it's a
better way to do it you know as a hacker
I want to help people by hacking around
the problems but by policy decisions
changing though problems don't exist to
begin with and
policymakers need our voice in our
understanding Code for America with this
program you're away for nine months
you're with the team of three people
again working to make government better
this is a job opening that's actually a
normal salary I know you guys are like
well those numbers right hürmüz
it's competitive but because I'm a cyber
person kind of InfoSec person this is
more for those people so if you're
curious about security if you feel like
you can advise people and talk to them
about it this is to help the Hewlett
Foundation decide like how best to spend
these cybersecurity funds and this
application if you're interested take a
picture of that and just check it out as
soon as possible okay so what if you
don't want to take all this money and
start your may big startup or mini
startup actually right and what if you
don't want to go away on sabbatical or
find a new job and go get a fellowship I
mean you might as well just it's like a
lottery just enter us what I say worry
about it they pick you could be like
yeah I want to do it you know flipping
someone else but if you don't want to do
that either how else can we do good we
can go to conferences because conference
budgets are cray right and it's like use
it or lose it right we can go to
conferences that actually help us feed
that part of ourselves and get us more
on line with our politics conferences
where our voices actually change events
in this world so that's what these are
let's do for the future has an event
coming up in Palo Alto call
reconfiguring reality which is super
creepy from a group called the Institute
but I believe in it you know I'm gonna
be there you know I'm gonna be there
talking to these leaders and listening
to them as well you know and watching
presentations and if any of you live in
Palo Alto reach out to the Institute say
your instant you're interested in
finding out how you can attend there's a
group called aspiration tech
a group that probably a lot of people
here who's heard of aspiration tech
anybody whoa I got to give you something
okay
aspiration tech is an organization that
works with nonprofits open source
developers right make sure that they can
build tools that activists need if you
go to the aspiration tech nonprofit
developer summit just check it out it's
in Oakland anyone's in the San Francisco
Oakland kind of Bay Area check it out
you know you'll you'll meet activists
from around this country and maybe even
around this world hear about their real
problems and you'll laugh at how easy it
is to find a tech solution to it
aspiration can help you get funding even
get the right people to solve these
problems I found that these developers
who work in the nonprofit space these
developers who work an open-source arm
these real problems they're doing
amazing things and they're highly
skilled I was working when I worked for
CNN in the New York Times you know our
user stories we were trying to delight
users we were trying to help customers
you know spend their money or get their
thing you know jump in their car and get
to where they're going but here we're
actually assisting human beings
there's the Chaos Computer Club which
that conference is in December so if you
hit your family doesn't go to it right
during the holidays right I go to Chaos
Computer Club conference this year it's
in Leipzig normally it was in Hamburg
but that conference center sold out once
a year for this conference they were
like the only time we make money we got
us you know make this place smaller and
the conference could not be there if
you're interested even a little bit in
application security security at all or
if you're not interested at all but you
have something to contribute as someone
who you know is a master of agile or
user experience or design because if
you've used any of these apps that will
keep people alive you'll realize that
they're designed horribly you know when
you go to Chaos Computer Club
there their conference is the 34th one
you'll meet people from like I've met
people who have only known as handles on
IRC you know I met people who you know I
had to meet with in like a random bar
and like tyro and here they are walking
around you know it's like the world
comes to you so even though your
family's here and the conference is
there it's worth it because so many
people attend so definitely look into it
if you not heard of him at least the ten
once there's a conference called the
internet Freedom Festival which is near
and dear to my heart it was started as
the circumvention technology conference
but that was a kind of weird Kalinka
conference name right what do you think
yeah all right so Internet Freedom
Festival it was it's in Valencia Spain
so I know it's a hardship to go to
Valencia and eat oranges and drink fresh
orange juice in the Sun but um the
conference is usually like like a week
or something but I think it's only gonna
be like four or five days next year
think about going it doesn't cost
anything I think your manager is gonna
love that just got to get your hotel and
your flight covered you'll meet the
people who write the tales operating
system tour the you know the the browser
that secures where you are how you're
browsing protects your privacy you know
people who work on signal people work on
apps that you've never heard of people
who need those apps from Iran Iraq
Africa like countries like Zimbabwe
Nigeria I remember I was working with
LGBTQ IP folks in um South Africa you
know it's really dangerous there and as
an activist just fighting to liberate
your people and be yourself be your true
self you can be killed the group I
worked with gathered these people we met
and I help them with their digital
security stuff and some of those people
I saw later at this conference ifs
república 17 is kind of like South by
Southwest but German I know it's kind of
weird it's insane it's like super huge
giant conference halls a media all over
the place there's people there from apps
and put on all kinds of code development
things that you've heard of but a lot of
it's very European and you know for
people who consider themselves really
global I've meet so many developers who
don't realize that people solve problems
differently in other parts of the world
and when you go to república you'll see
this and meet people who think totally
different you know luckily for us in
this room if you can understand my voice
English is like the bridge language for
all these developers but it república
that's where everybody comes so it's
more of like a spectacle you know but I
think they call it something like the
like it's very inspirational
you know you'll leave it feeling really
great about the people you met and the
work you're doing right connoisseur the
rights Kahn I know right it's crazy
right in my world that well then rides
come on you know rights Kahn is a
conference run by this group called
access now access now does stuff in this
world that a lot of us probably think
PFF does you know they have a helpdesk
where if you know how to write an
encrypted email you can get an answer so
a bunch of Mexican activists working on
this like sugar soda campaign started
writing those encrypted emails to access
now they said hey they didn't even know
that they all were doing it I'm getting
these weird messages on my phone my kids
phone is this weird text on it access
now tuck this to a group call citizen
lab which is in Toronto and they found
that an organization was using an
exploit a bug in iPhones that if you
click on this link they can take over
your entire phone see through your
camera hear through your microphone
it's a bug that Apple did not know about
when citizen lab told Apple they patched
it and made a change access now is kind
of like on the front lines of all these
weird things that happened to activists
around the world because of that
helpdesk and they share it with security
researchers and trainers like myself and
because of that we have
a little bit of a heads up on what's
coming because those applications that
are used by organizations like Anna so
group to hack these activists you know
they charge like six hundred fifty
thousand dollars for ten iPhones they're
like look we have a bug that Apple
doesn't know about you give us that
money and the 10 iPhone numbers and we
got you you know that could be anyone in
this room access now writes calm super
amazing and this year it's usually
overseas like last year was in Brussels
and I went and then this year it was
maybe going to be in the States but it's
in Toronto cuz it's easier for the folks
to get their travel bans etc right so if
you can get to Toronto you can convince
yourself and people you work with to
send you please do this hearing these
stories will change your life and also
realizing how our gift of tech can go so
far the Oslo Freedom Forum is another
like huge conference in my world you
know it is like Ted but the talks are
like eight minutes long and every talk
hits you right in your heart the Oslo
Freedom Forum you'll hear someone talk
about I was poisoned by the FSB formerly
KGB Russian security forces twice you
know or I'm a opposition political
figure in an African nation
I need help is there anything this new
technology can do to help me you know
you'll hear stories I went this year
there was an event in New York and there
was someone from Venezuela he
communicated with his violin playing
music and telling stories of his friends
who died to the left and right of him
protesting because they were hungry if
you can't go to any of these conferences
please donate sixty minutes of your life
and just watch the videos every one of
them except for maybe iff is recorded
you know you can go to the Chaos
Computer Club Media DC CDE and watch
videos from bygone era of hacking one of
my favorite conference is is for in
Detroit called allied media outlet media
conference is like a very queer
very people who self identify as women
centered very Brown
I mean activists there from all parts of
this nation people who were anti-fascist
who later I'd see in videos in
Charlottesville
people who are fighting for gay rights
people who are seeing that these laws
are being pushed back and just fighting
for some air you know most of the people
at allied media are really young and
they inspire me you know just living
their best lives being their true selves
it's so brave
there'll be an event on the session list
there that's like Tai Chi for yoga moms
you know or like Hair Braiding for
anarchist but there's also events on
cryptography on operational security for
people who actually use this to do
things you know it's really amazing to
hear like detect that they use the way
that they use it their stories it's very
inspirational but they need us there
because there are almost no
technologists at allied media conference
so if you're near Detroit or you can go
just check it out it's the 20th
anniversary he's gonna be lit okay my
pointy thing I don't know what's going
on it's not pointing whoa okay if you
want to start slowly and not go to a
conference right I don't want to go to a
conference I don't want to take all this
money from the government's I definitely
want to go into sabbatical right what
can I do you can work at a place like
thought works right like they're a
for-profit company but they're known for
their social good projects but did you
know that you might be working at that
company right now our company that's
for-profit that actually does social
good that's right you got to look at the
company in the mirror okay
so man in the mirror joke okay so a lot
of the companies that we work for
they'll give you like eight hours to to
do a charity event
no like they'll give you like a day or a
week off
like it's right there in like if you go
talk to HR your manager to you know run
a 10k or something like that but it
doesn't need to be that you can say hey
um can I work with this group down the
street and build something for them like
a website and they'll be like yeah
that's fine
so that's social good and you'll get
paid for that day you'll get paid for
that week you'll get paid for that 10k
run time you know it's something that
the organizations that we've worked for
and what like the Conor groups that and
companies that I worked for when I work
for big corporations they need to do
that you know they need to show that
they're giving back you know any
accountant any tax person will tell you
it's a smart move so find out you might
be able to do that little skunk work
project or that little idea for a friend
company done okay we got three minutes
left folks this is our planet it's ours
and it's beautiful politics are changing
all over this world the weather is
changing all over this world I believe
like I've always believed that
technology is the answer but technology
is just our tool because we're the
wizards we're the magicians every woman
out there every man out there every
gender nonconforming person out there
it's for us to protect this planet
because we know that with our keyboards
and mice we can do the work of hundreds
of people so please take care of each
other and please take care of this
amazing planet okay humans thank you
[Applause]